hello everyone my name is saurabh and
i'm part of the simply learn team
welcome everyone today to this session
of blockchain so let's get started so
before the blockchain came into industry
let's see how typical transactions used
to happen let's check an example of a
property transaction which used to
happen in the past now when two parties
have to do a transaction of property
which is a very high value transaction
there always used to be an intermediary
involved now that intermediary is a
broker who facilitates the transaction
between the buyer and the seller and
using the land record the documents he
manages the documents he gets all the
documents verified and he is the primary
trust person between the buyer and
seller to get the transaction done now
in the due course some things can go
wrong the broker can make alterations to
the data or the broker can by mistake
make errors in his own personal records
or the records of the buyer and the
seller now considering it's a very
sensitive transaction at a high value if
any problem comes into picture then both
the buyer and seller can suffer huge
losses now let's take another example of
a banking transaction if a sender wants
to send money to a receiver typically in
today's scenario or till now before the
cryptocurrencies and the blockchain
technologies came into picture we rely
on banks you transfer money to a
centralized bank which takes the
ownership and gives you the trust to
transfer the money to the receiver and
in lieu charges a commission but things
can go wrong here too either of your
accounts can get hacked or the bank can
go under some technical issues or you
could have exceeded the number of
transfer the limits alerted to you but
with the virtue of cryptocurrencies
today we can do these transactions with
lower transaction cost as compared to
what bank charges and it's a 24 7
available technology which you can use
so basically the evolution of such a
technology has come into picture in
order to reduce the dependency on
intermediaries to reduce the transaction
cost and we do not have any limitations
of transfer limits per day or the amount
which you can transfer so we will take a
look what is the evolution of the
technology blockchain now in 2008 when a
person or a group of individuals called
satoshi nakamoto published a white paper
in order to introduce a currency called
bitcoin in order to change the life
forever for people who were dependent on
the banking transaction for making any
financial transaction they introduced a
democratic currency which was barrier
free and which allowed payment across
multiple geographies with low
transaction fees so this is how bitcoin
came into picture a cryptocurrency that
solved several of fiat currency's
problems for example it is accessible by
anyone it is protected by cryptography
it is decentralized there is no
centralized authority owning the network
or taking care of the transactions it is
the network and the participants in the
network who are taking care of all the
transactions and the sanity of the
network and the anonymity of all the
users are ensured and bitcoin
uses what is called as blockchain
technology as its underlying technology
so what's in it for us today we will be
talking about what is blockchain what is
bitcoin typical features of blockchain
like public distributed ledger hashing
encryptions the proof of work consensus
algorithm the mining techniques how do
miners gain money and other fields where
blockchain is applicable now what is
blockchain blockchain is a digital
ledger that stores transaction details
these records are stored and aggregated
in containers called blocks these blocks
are linked to each other and are secured
using cryptography now let's take a look
at the typical features blockchain is
something which is available for anyone
to access data can only be added we
cannot alter any information which is
added to a blockchain and that is called
its immutability feature to add any data
a typical mathematical puzzle has to be
solved by the validators of the network
or so-called miners in order to maintain
the sanity of the network and in you
they receive a reward the solution has
to be approved by everyone in the
network the participants of the network
are responsible for approving all the
transactions there is no central
authority which has control over the
information and that's why a blockchain
network is a democratic network the
privacy of all the users is maintained
by cryptography and the transactions
which also happen on the blockchain
network are encrypted now what is
bitcoin bitcoin is a digital currency
that uses cryptography to limit how much
of it exists at a time it is also used
to verify transfer of assets and secure
financial transactions bitcoin uses
blockchain technology so there is a
limit to the supply of bitcoin only 21
million are bound to be supplied in the
network as of today around 26.5 to 17
million has already been mined and are
available in the network for
transactions so what are the features of
bitcoin they don't work under a central
authority transferring assets is faster
as compared to fiat currency
transferring assets is costlier with
fiat currencies so as we have seen the
cryptocurrency market removes the need
of intermediaries more the
intermediaries the higher is the
transaction cost therefore whenever we
are doing a transaction with virtual
currencies or currencies like bitcoin or
other cryptocurrencies the transaction
cost is bound to be lower as compared to
any freight currency payments are
secured by cryptography any transaction
which you make using a bitcoin you are
doing the transaction using your private
key and public key so we will take a
look how the encryption works and how
any transaction is encapsulated in an
encrypted envelope and then floated onto
the network identities of the parties
who are who are doing transaction using
bitcoin are kept anonymous and it uses
blockchain as its underlying technology
now what are the typical features of
blockchain blockchain has four major
features that make it special it is a
public distributed ledger it uses
hashing encryption it uses proof of work
kind of consensus algorithm and it has
entities like miners who are constantly
working to maintain the validity of all
the transactions on the blockchain
network to keep the network sanitized
now what is a public distributed ledger
a public distributed ledger is a
collection of digital data which is
shared available to all the participants
on the network it is synchronized
everyone is having the same set of copy
of data it is a replicated shared ledger
across the world across multiple sites
across the boundaries across countries
and institutions so consider a
blockchain that can be accessed by
anyone in the network around the world
but suppose someone decides to alter the
data he or she can go and change one of
the blocks but everyone every
participant on the network has a copy of
the ledger so it will be very easy to
find that there is a block which is
different from what others are having
thereby it will be very fast in order to
identify that which block is altered or
tampered and they can easily discard
that particular block from the network
and the data tampering can be prevented
encryption blockchain uses cryptography
to ensure the blocks are kept secure
from unauthorized access and alteration
blockchain uses sha-256
encryption algorithm for encryption to
validate users blockchain also makes use
of digital signature whenever a user
onboards a typical blockchain network he
generates his or her own public and
private key pair the public key is used
to uniquely identify the user and the
private key gives the user access to
everything in his or her own account now
let's see what happens in a typical
sender and receiver transaction when a
sender wants to send a message that
message is passed to the hashing
function which in our case is the
sha-256 then the output of that hashing
function is passed through a signature
algorithm with the user's private key
and this is how a digital signature is
obtained from the sender side now once a
digital signature has been generated the
message the digital signature and the
public key these three things are
transmitted on the public blockchain now
at the receiver end the message is
passed again through the cryptographic
function on the reverse side to get a
hash value now that hash value is
compared with the hash output obtained
by passing the digital signature and the
public key through a verification
function so the hash output of both the
functions should match and that's how
the authenticity of the message is being
validated now each block in a blockchain
uses sha-256
to secure its data now this is a typical
structure of a header of a block which
we are taking a look at every block in
the blockchain has four fields it has a
previous hash it has transaction details
it has nonce and a hash address the
value of previous hash transaction
details and nons are passed through a
hashing function to produce a unique
hash address for a particular block and
that hash address basically becomes the
identity of block which is unique across
the network now what is previous hash
this field is used to store the hash
value of the previous block of the
blockchain and this is how
we are linking a new block to its
previous block a block always contain
aggregation of several transactions
these details are placed in this field
called as transaction details nonce is a
random value which is used to generate a
hash which should be less than the
target value allotted to a block at a
particular time the hash address is the
unique identification of the block it is
a hex value of 64 characters that has
both letters and digits and it is
obtained using two sha-256 algorithm and
this is the unique identity of every
block on the blockchain network now what
is proof of work proof of work is a
competition amongst the people or
so-called miners around the world who
are constantly working on a public
blockchain network and who want to add a
block to the blockchain that is the
primary objective of the miners to add a
block to the blockchain they are
constantly working to find the noun's
value which is the mathematical puzzles
that the miner need to solve it is the
process of finding an appropriate nonce
that helps generate a hash value that
satisfied certain predetermined
conditions which are called as a target
the first one the first miner to find
the nonce value gets rewarded for it he
spreads the word amongst all other
miners about finding the noun's value
and a minus claim is also very easy to
identify now choosing a nonce value this
is the primary objective of the miner
they have to find a nonce value which
has to be less than the target value if
they find a value greater than the
target then their mining effort is
rejected but if they find a value hash
value and if they are successfully able
to generate that hash value using the
nouns and which is less than the target
value then the effort is accepted and
this is where the entire computational
and hardware power of a miner is used in
order to generate that nonce value in a
stipulated amount of time and that's why
they invest in that hardware in order to
return get a reward which is their
return on investment mining a miner
would be able to find announce value
while using up a lot of time money and
resources the miner then spreads the
word about finding this value other
miners attempt to validate this claim
that whether the miner who is claiming
the value is correct or not and if
verified by the other miners then only
the miner gets rewarded mining is the
process of miner being rewarded for
being the first one to find the nonce
the mathematical puzzle as of today a
miner is rewarded with 12.5 bitcoins as
a form of compensation but the amount of
bitcoins as a reward gets half every
four years because there is a limited
supply of bitcoin thereby that logic is
already been placed in the bitcoin
network mining ensures that there is a
limit to how much bitcoin can exist in
the market mining is the only way new
bitcoins can be generated and there is
no other way that a new bitcoin can come
into existence into the network there
are other areas potential areas where
the blockchain can be applicable
blockchain has been identified and is
being used in other industries as well
for example travel to ease the
verification of documents to make the
processing of documents and transactions
in travel and tourism seamless real time
hotel inventories it's also one of the
use cases for travel and tourism
industries on blockchain music industry
music industry is using blockchain to
stop music piracy and compensate artists
for the songs which they have created
and are being purchased online cyber
security data integrity can be
guaranteed there cannot be a single
point of failure human resources
authenticity of employment history
authenticity of the identity of
employees payments and benefits process
validation these are all the areas where
blockchain is getting used now let's
take a look at a demo now i am going to
show you a typical example of how a sha
256 cryptography works now this is a
sample input and when i will say make
hash this is a 256 length character hash
which has been generated the beauty of
sha-256 is that whatever be the input it
will always generate a 256 length hash
the hash has changed but the length is
the same
now let's take a look at a typical
blockchain now here we are seeing the
first block in a typical blockchain
which is called the genesis block and as
it is the first block in the blockchain
the previous hash value of this block is
all zeros because it is the first block
now if you notice the body has certain
set of transactions which are there
available to be mined and once this
block will be mined then only i'll be
able to add any subsequent block to it
now once i'll mine this block it will
turn green it means that the block has
been verified and validated on the
network and a hash which is the
signature of this block has been
generated now i'll be able to add a
block the new block has newly aggregated
transactions and the point to be noted
is that the previous hash value has been
populated in this section which
basically links the block to the
previous block now once i mine this then
again this block turns into green and
this is how a typical blockchain is
created now let's take a look how a
typical transaction a financial
transaction happens on a blockchain we
have four users here who have their
wallets with hundred dollars now and we
are doing it a decentralized transaction
so wallet one would like to send one
dollar to wallet two now the transaction
has been initiated and it is pending at
in the pending transaction section
either of these miners which are there
on this network can mine the transaction
validate it and thereby once they have
validated the wallet 2 has been credited
with the one dollar now thing to be
noted here is the block 2 which has been
added had that transaction here and if
you see the previous block section this
is the address of the previous block
hash on the block and 0094 e this is the
hash of this block itself now suppose i
add another transaction from wallet 2 to
wallet 3 and say mine another block has
got added and to note again block three
previous hash is the hash value of block
two and block three's own hash starts
with zero zero three d a what have we
learned so far we have learned what is
blockchain what is bitcoin public
distributed ledger proof of work hashing
encryption and mining hope you had a
great learning experience and i'll meet
you in another session thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here